very excited to have shireen williams on
the show another legend we got a show
full of legends today nothing but
legends
welcome to the show she knows all things
football all things texas football and i
want to
start shireen with uh tj's dallas
cowboys
um he's already pre-gaming for his super
bowl party right here in los angeles
is he a little premature you think well
first i you know i'm disappointed i'm
not in the studio with you guys because
it sounds like you're having way too
much fun
with drinks and everything else going on
so
so a lot of fun there um yeah you know
i think the cowboys have a chance
because i think their defense is going
to be better i think that's the key for
them offensively we know what they have
right
now i do think there's a little bit of
concern despite what the cowboys have
said publicly about oh there's no
concern with that
shoulder it's going to be fine i just i
i think there's a little bit of concern
there that with this strain
and it's early i get it you know but i
would i would like
to see him play in the preseason to take
that hit that would be the next step for
him
uh to get through that hurdle of all
right i've
taken off and run and gotten hit and my
ankle's fine and all those things and he
says he never
thinks about it anymore and i get that
to see go to mile when he went out and
danced and that was a good sign that he
was able to do that and i do think he's
100
and all that but there is that hurdle to
clear right that mental hurdle of really
taking that first hit so i would like to
see him play some of the preseasons
and i don't know with this shoulder
injury we'll see it again it's early he
wasn't going to play in the hall of fame
game anyway
but we'll see what happens but i would
like to see him play in the preseason so
i do think there's a little bit of
concern there but i do think they're
better
i they've certainly got a chance to win
the nfc east we know how bad it was last
year
i i think they got the best quarterback
in the division
um so they have a chance to do that and
once you get playoffs you never know
what's going to happen
and they haven't been we don't know the
history you haven't been back to the
championship game since 1995 which is
the last time they won the super bowl so
it's been a really long time
but this does look like a pretty good
team on paper we know what that
equals out to not very much once the
season starts but but i like the looks
of of things that they've done this
offseason and during training camp
shereen williams joins the show pro
football talk you can follow her on
twitter at
nfl shereen ben line's in for rich on
the rich eisen show and i bring up your
twitter sharing because
i think you've had the tweet of this
young football season you called out
young players yesterday or two days ago
now if you're a young player seeking to
make the team
you do not leave the field until
everyone else has
you certainly don't leave the field
before the quarterback with the video of
dak prescott running wind sprints
calling out the next generation shireen
i like it
well that to me said more about their
young players than it said about dak
prescott right he's out there running
extra wind sprints after practice if
he's out there your butt better be out
there if you're trying to make the team
i mean i don't care i don't care how
tired you are i don't care that your
other position group's gone in i don't
care
if the starting quarterbacks out there
running wind sprints after practice you
better be out there you better be seen
by those coaches and
one thing i really liked about calamon
of course i'm an aggie so i've
i've seen every game that calaman has
played in his career
and but with the vikings he was the
first guy on the practice field every
single
day before he got covered of course but
first guy on the practice field i loved
seeing that and was not surprised to see
that
but that's what you want to see from
young players you need to be out there
well before practicing you just stay
after practice until the last guy's gone
certainly before the quarterback's gone
that's what teams need to see they need
to see your commitment
to this thing that you're doing
everything possible to make the team so
absolutely i
i love that zach was still out there
running wind sprints didn't surprise me
but it did surprise me that other guys
weren't out there
sharing i will run through a wall for
you you have me fired up
jacked up you are absolutely right when
you see the quarterback out there
running wind sprints you get out there
and run wind sprints that's it
i like it what's going on with the other
team in texas what's happening with the
texans
are they going to put on professional
football games this year yeah you know
and i feel so bad for david culley he's
a good friend of mine we go but
way way way back and we both started our
careers basically together at a
m i was covering them full time and and
he was a young coach there
and so we kind of we went to tampa
together at the same time so
we've kind of moved through the ranks
together and so happy to see him finally
get a head coaching
job which he tells me is going to be his
last coaching job which he would think
it would be and
whatever happens but he's such a good
coach and such a good motivator for guys
and i know the guys have
certainly taken a liking to him right
away they love what he brings but
there's just not much talent there and
you look at that team and you wonder how
they're going to win any games at all we
you know you figure they're going to win
one or two and the division
certainly does not look very good
outside of tennessee so they'll have a
chance to win
some of those games within the division
no question
but i'm really sad for him that this is
his first head coaching opportunity and
this is what he has to work with because
it doesn't look very good
and they certainly look like the worst
team in the nfl
this season maybe no surprise maybe
they'll win a few games and
and do some something unexpected but uh
you know again
on paper i it just they don't look very
good to me
shereen williams joins the show pro
football talk ben lyons
in for rich on the rich eisen show we've
been celebrating tom brady's
44th birthday today just going to town
on some kombucha some sunflower seeds
some kale chips really getting crazy
here in the studio
but i wonder shireen is there anybody
out there in the nfc that you think
really can rival tb12 and the tampa bay
buccaneers when they run it back this
year
well i think you know the first team to
look at right is the packers just
because
they did get aaron rodgers back and they
got to the nfc championship game and
they actually hosted that game and who
knows maybe if they had gone for the
touchdown
instead of kicking the field goal maybe
they end up pulling that game out who
knows
so you know i think that's a team you
look at right away
as as being the contender to knock off
the buccaneers i think they're clearly
the second best team
in the nfc and i know all those teams in
the nfc west look good to me
you know i i like what they all bring
but you know
we keep talking about the rams and
matthew stafford and
you know he's going to be able to get
the ball down the field and all that but
i got to see it i mean this guy who
hasn't won a playoff game
and hasn't done what we thought he
should have done in the postseason even
when he had some good teams
uh in detroit and that was a while ago
so i'm going to have to see it
with matthew stafford and the rams
clearly probably the best team he's
played with in his career but i'm going
to have to see it
before i believe it with the rams and
you know seattle was worth the wilson
are they going to be able to get over
that
play on pump that they haven't been able
to do since early in russell's career
when they had those back-to-back super
bowl appearances and that's part of the
problem
uh with him being disgruntled with that
team is just the lack of postseason
success since then and they just haven't
shown they can get it done in the
postseason and
now the cardinals again on paper they
look terrific but is
kyler murray going to take that next
step a lot of it falls on his shoulders
and
so you look at those teams in the west
and i think they all
look like they're pretty good teams one
of them is
going to have to be better than the
others and we're in the division
obviously
who that's going to be i couldn't say to
me they're all contenders for that
division title right now but i i think
clearly it's the packers if you if you
start looking
everywhere else if the packers are going
to be the biggest
um contender for the buccaneers and that
and in the division
how are the saints going to be who's
going to be their quarterback and you
know i think they're going to win a lot
of games i think they're going to be in
the playoffs i love sean payton
i think he's one of the best coaches if
not the best coach in the nfl perhaps
outside of bill belichick but you know
how's the quarterback situation going to
be and again that's just a big question
mark so
to me the bucks and and the packers and
we started out by question marks those
are the two teams in
the nfc that you go they don't have a
whole lot of question marks like we
know what they are these other teams we
don't know what they are maybe this one
of them turns out to be great and has a
terrific season
but right now today all the rest of them
have a ton of question marks
shereen williams joins the show ben
lines in for rich on the rich eisen show
shireen earlier on we had greg rosenthal
from nfl network call in and he was
talking about how for reporters people
like yourselves who cover the league
just really nice to be able to be back
at training camps and to be out seeing
people
obviously the world shut down the last
year and a half or so you weren't able
to have that experience
last football season what's it like for
you as somebody who's covered the league
for a long time just to be back
at camp sort of back on your more normal
beat and schedule if you will
yeah you know it's it was such a weird
year
and yeah i'm looking for the uh hall of
fame and homestead game and the
ceremonies on thursday and
and we'll get some cowboys camp when
they come back and probably will get
down to houston to see the taxes a
little bit so it's nice to be able to go
to some of these
camps and see it in person and you know
and and to be able to go to some
pre-season you know we had the preseason
last year so we're a lot of unknowns
going into last season more than usual
we do have a lot of unknowns but more
than usual last year just because we
didn't have the preseason games
to see some of these uh young players
see them develop like
they like they normally would develop in
the preseason when they get those
i mean snaps are just so important but
from our standpoint it's just
it it's great to be back it's great to
to talk to these people in person and
see them and
and all those sorts of things and even
the media you know these are your
friends and you haven't seen them for
now a year and a half and uh it's just
been a long time but a weird year we're
here for everybody i get it but we're
even despite the delta variant we're
starting to return to a little bit
closer to normalcy i think it's going to
be another year before we get back
totally normal but it's nice to have
these opportunities to interview people
in person and see people in person
shireen i was on the show about a week
or two ago when jerry jones had his
annual
kick off the season press conference and
this year he said something that was a
little concerning he said that he would
do
anything willing anything known to man
to win a super ball which had us in the
studio
really questioning what depths he might
go to in a man's soul to win a super
bowl
what did you make by jerry's press
conference where he's on his life
journey
and career with this cowboy team this
year you know i
haven't known jerry pretty well and had
a chance to
present him for the hall of fame and
some of those things um
you know i i i think he's seen the end
and he knows that you know just based on
his age he's not going to have a ton
more chances we talk about windows all
the time his
is a little different window uh for
different reasons
you know because of his age and and he
sees that thing closing
a little bit each year you know
attention none of us know how long we
have but
his window obviously is inching down
each year that that's a year
that he doesn't win another super bowl
that's gone by
and there's one fewer years that he gets
a chance to do that and
again it's been 1995 since they were
there in one one and
and he never in a million years thought
it would take that long to to get back
to the super bowl and
who knows maybe he never he never gets
back there maybe his team never gets
back there before he's gone and and i
hope they do
i hope he gets to see that and and gets
the win another one there's nobody
quite like jerry in the nfl but i do
think that's a big
part of how emotional he was
there is one thing i know for a fact
that he wouldn't give up to get a super
bowl and that's that gold jacket that
means an
awful lot to him and he said it a couple
times that he wouldn't give up his spot
in the whole thing for another super
bowl
but as my husband has pointed out if he
won another super bowl then he would get
back
into back into the hall of fame with
four super bowls on his resume so i
think he'd be
safe there but yeah he'd write a check
for however big
it took to win a super bowl if he could
do that
shereen williams joins the show pro
football talk you can follow her on
twitter at nfl
shireen something we've been talking
about all week long with the various
reporters who've been kind enough to
share their expertise their insights to
make us better
and smarter here on the rich eisen show
something we've been talking about with
them
is who would do well in a survivorless
situation for nfl reporters nba
reporters
are you comfortable building a fire do
you think edward could build a fort
uh who do you think would do well in nfl
survivor for reporters
oh man that's a great question
you know i probably wouldn't survivor
like i love my showers and
being clean in my own bed and like i am
not a camper it would have to be
somebody who really loves
sleeping in a tent and being out in the
wilderness i just don't think i could do
it you know jimmy johnson went on
went on survivor and that was a goal of
all
of his to go on and do that so um
i don't know that many of us in the
media would be good at that to be honest
to be totally honest about it i don't
know that many of us would survive it's
probably uh
we probably all starve to death for sure
yeah i don't think
mike florio could hunt the squirrel and
uh
i want michael my team on that i mean
he's from west virginia he might
yeah it's true he might already be very
comfy he might know which type of
squirrel is the best squirrel who knows
that's a good point shireen shereen we
appreciate you coming on the show
thank you so much for spending some time
thank you guys
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here